so when we talk about budgeting uh there
are some blockers like I could feel it
through the camera that some people have
objections they're like Jade a budget
listen I've got too much to do already
my kids the math like I hate doing math
if you're talking about writing down
numbers others of you are like listen if
you knew my spouse you would know
there's no way they're sticking to a
budget or possibly you've tried a budget
before and it just didn't work for you
here's the thing you were probably doing
it wrong so we're going to teach you the
right way and the good news is every
dollar which is the best budgeting app
there is is going to make it so super
easy for you we're going to overcome
every single one of those objections
tonight and we're going to show you how
to build your every dollar budget in
five minutes